IR merci
euh
[Musique]
deuxième survol du village on part
direction Est merci Rog de
rien et euh passe une bonne journée merci
j'aime la lumière dans le noir sur l'
Ombre et le Soleil rend ça plus intéressant
que euh
[Rires]
hélicoptère parle trop tôt
un nuage sombre là le nuage sombre est
joli je l'ai pris en photo c'est
plutôt sympa ouais comme un
filtre gr on peut voir l'autre île pour
voir euh Bean Island peut-être pas celle-là
ok
j'espère savoir  ce qui est une bonne chose euh à quel
point les vents vont nous ralentir non
c'était euh derrière nous oh EXC pas si mal
tu payes beaucoup d'argent pour le Tailwind
oui c'était très cher hier
2 000 $ pour le Tailwind ouais
ok oh tu vois ils  White Caps Je connais la
glace
BS, il est environ 67 minutes, traversez 6,
ok, si vous vous endormez, faites-le-moi savoir et
je vous réveillerai,
ok, c'est le point sur mon épaule,
je me réveille ouais, ok, c'est le pilote automatique,
tapez sur l'épaule,
parfait
nord-est W.  direction vers Kim route 2000 pieds de
trafic dans Conflict on6 sur 7 Fox Victor
Hotel
xray
oh là un gros Iceberg
là-bas au large de
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
GL
[Rires]
[Musique]
en haut
ok euh Concentrez-vous ouais quoi  mieux c'est est
là
je cherche des bières polaires
nager
bronzer
ok ok euh
où sont-ils ok peux-tu
les montrer si tu les vois sont-ils là
oui je vais vers eux
oh il y en a quelques-uns peux-tu aller
t'incliner  roue trop vite ouais il y en a genre
six j'ai besoin que quelqu'un
les montre du doigt pour que je sache où ils sont
euh juste en dessous de toi à
droite tu les vois non non juste ici à
droite tu vois derrière toi derrière
nous
je vais en trouver d'autres
un très
bien c'est tout
132 secondes
sh la vitesse d'obturation
oh merci
ok juste une
pause ouais très
sympa puis tu fais un zoom
arrière maintenant on s'envole
sur la droite ici juste en dessous ok bang
around tu l'as ouais je l'ai je pense que
je  avoir oh
ouais un un bonjour
quoi un et le bébé deux deux
animaux
ouais oh
magnifique
j'essaie de ralentir ralentir l'ESP ralentir l'ESP
très lentement j'ai plus de contrôle sur la
caméra oh le petit bébé est
derrière
euh tu mets le dou
ouais
maintenant
prêt Stefan désolé désolé essaie le
[Musique]
dou prêt
ok bonne chance pour la concentration
ouais je juste un petit
peu euh je veux essayer D
d56 c'est quoi où ils s'arrêtent
ouais tu essaies le
56 on se tourne vers
sh arrête le L vers le bas arrête le  en bas, ça y est,
ils sont allés sous l'eau ouais, ils pourraient
revenir, ils reviendront
ok, ils reviennent à une
fois, ils s'arrêtent différents
ok,
ok, vois-en d'autres par
ici, arrête d'enregistrer [Rires
]
maintenant
[Rires]
ok,
pause
[Musique] c'est
vrai, tu vois
ah oh
les gars
c'est drôle parce qu'on peut les nuages ​​bas
ouais et bien Ciel bleu aux nuages ​​bas oh il y
a un hélicoptère Ombre ouais qui a mis
ça là
non oh
attends
ok quoi d'
autre
euh
lame ok pause
d'
où pointe-t-il c'est la
droite sur le
fore étranger étranger
d'accord, fais
une
pause un instant, je vais juste essayer de
polariser un peu
[Musique], ça a l'
air vraiment sympa, tu as mis le polar ride
non, je viens d'éteindre le polariseur
en fait, oh l'un ou l'autre polarise dans
l'autre
sens, un nuage passe dessus  le Top
Shot
milles
2822 et
beau bon
après midi hélicoptère Victor 14 milles
au nord-est de w estimé en 7
minutes
iee spee
Peter je pense qu'on va
traverser entre les deux montagnes tu connais
à droite ok ce petit Gap ou à
droite de  vers la fin ouais
juste entre les deux
pour
Bo
up c'est l'emblème d'un
boomerang c'est une photo que j'ai
choisie et Yan a pris la photo en
Finlande, à
l'étranger,
des ours polaires non oh pourquoi
pas on ne les appelle pas comme ça  matin, nous
ne leur avons pas réservé
[Musique]
leur
âge
[Musique]
hé [
Musique]
juste une pause un
instant Victor nous sommes
ouais en fait à 8 miles
à l'ouest d'accord et nous Le dans 3
[Musique]
minutes
et est-il possible d'appeler le  le carburant B
pour
Victor
R la
lame
pour
est-ce que
le petit village est juste derrière la
colline juste
là
après avoir encore joué
au football
non
d'accord sur le
F non non
non
wow tu veux prendre une autre photo du
village non non je vais bien je  je suis content que
tu vas bien hein non non la lumière va
bien la lumière est meilleure maintenant qu'avant mais
non c'est bien avant
ouais ouais ter est toujours c'est allumé
je veux le vérifier